this football pitch is a refuge an
outlet to vent and a place to find help
life isn't easy for people of African
descent in Poland a country that is more
than 96 white nigerian-born arenze set
up this group for black people to
express themselves in a public space
he's been racially profiled and
violently attacked it called me monkey
what are you doing in Poland go back to
Africa he had to close his business
because of what he calls racism and
xenophobia a life about black people
here in in Poland is very difficult
it's very difficulty in every aspect
they don't want to give apartment to
Africans we know we are black we just
need to accept that we are all human
beings so it's all about acceptance just
to accept who we are I'm proud of who I
am and I'll always be black arenze is a
Polish national he says life is even
more difficult for refugees and Asylum
Seekers according to the U.N
non-ukrainians don't enjoy the same
legal protections
Poland has accepted more than a million
refugees from Ukraine but there is a
toxic debate around migrants based on
their religion ethnicity and even the
color of their skin
a 2018 campaign ad by the governing
party maintains an influx of immigrants
will cause a wave of rape and violence
other political parties spread similar
messages of division
this opposition leader and former
president of the European Council Donald
Tusk criticizes the government for
welcoming migrants from the Middle East
and African countries
analysts say xenophobia has Deep Roots
for Polish Society is still very
monocultural in other words simply very
white we lack people of a different skin
color who we'd normally see on the
street the acceptance of various types
of otherness is low in Polish Society
this does not apply to migrants of a
different skin color but to all people
who stand out
Sasha left her home in Ukraine When The
War Began she volunteers at this
Community Kitchen her experience of
Poland has been very different
it's maybe easiest for us to find job
and have some kind of help but what I
see about other refugees like they have
more problems when people from our
kitchen
like not from slavenic group tried to
find flat and they couldn't I would like
people feel what we feel in general that
we hear not because we want to like it's
just life decided that we should be
somewhere
else no
and that acceptance is what all refugees
want wherever they come from Warsaw